[Music]
I'm like one day at a time at this point
Shannon Doherty's cancer has now spread
to her brain the actress shared the
diagnosis in an emotional new video
that's the hard part Shannon said that's
the 52 year old with tears in her eyes
receiving radiation therapy after a CT
scan back in January revealed her breast
cancer cells had spread Shannon writes
the turmoil the timing of it all this is
what cancer can look like everybody's
terminal it's imperative that you keep
on top of things open your mouth wide
the 90210 star was also fitted with this
radiation mask which keeps the head
still during treatment the worst day was
the confirmation that I had cancer since
Her diagnosis in 2015 Shannon has been
candid and open about her cancer Journey
the hair loss the radiation her
gratitude for every single moment
unpresent and
and more in the moment than I ever have
been in my life but Shannon is real and
candid about the challenges of treatment
quote I am extremely claustrophobic and
there was a lot going on in my life I
wish I could do it for her six weeks ago
Shannon filed for divorce from her
husband Kurt is warianko after 11 years
of marriage and back in March she said
she lost her sag after health insurance
Shannon told E.T the stigma of Her
diagnosis prevented her from finding
work you get written off so quickly even
though you're still vital and healthy
and happy and wanting to you know go out
there and work while we send love to
Shannon let's move on to another celeb
speaking out about a time in crisis
Arnold Schwarzenegger he's opening up
about the cheating scandal that ended
his marriage Marie and I went to council
once a week and then at one of the
sessions the council said I think the
day Maria wants to go and be very
specific about something she wants to
know if you're the father of Joseph I
thought mayor heart stopped
and then I told the truth yes Maria
Joseph is my son
she was you know obviously crushed
because of that he was wrong what I did
but I don't want to make Joseph feel
that he's not welcome in this world
because he's very much welcome in this
world
and I love him the three-part series
Arnold premiered today on Netflix I'm
very happy within this sad story that
Maria and I were able to raise the kids
really well
[Music]